you know I look at the military and
there's so many concerning components of
that to me
um are you worried about a military now
that's not only woke they're sitting and
watching woke videos it looks like
cartoons child's cartoons they're not
prepared for the next big fight and you
have many people in this country and
outside this country that are fully
encouraging a World War III I'm
certainly not one of them are you
concerned about an unprepared military
and do you feel like the military is
some sort of agent of the state meaning
are they just a voice for you know uh
big Pharma now are they just a voice for
the system as opposed to really doing
their job which is to train people to be
on the front lines of combat end of
story to win if we need them out there
to win are they too woke and too
centralized
I am so that is a different uh that is
an area I'm very concerned with because
I think when it comes down to the
military side because it's so organized
and they're reporting from top down on
what to do and it's all about yes ma'am
yes sir don't question just do as you're
told it's such a do as you're told and
don't question which is problematic
because in a corporate environment when
you're sitting in a boardroom I'm just
see I'm the chairman of the board right
but when I'm in a boardroom not
everybody agrees with me nobody sits
there and says yeah what about this
though what if we do this how about that
I think we should try this out no I
don't think that's a good product I
don't want to do this how about if we do
this part in business it's debate right
even in politics is debate but in
military your tattoo you know yes sir no
sir so like I'm sitting there talking to
a couple of these military guys saying
you guys should have known this
Afghanistan idea wasn't a good idea why
did you still do it because we can't do
anything what do you mean you can't do
anything do you mean to tell me you're
sitting there knowing you're on the
field you're there you see this stuff
every day you still said yes to the
order coming down from McKinsey or
whoever was yes why didn't McKinsey
question anything he just didn't have
the backbone to question anything so
that part is a little bit worrisome to
me the fact that it's too much of an
environment of just you got to do what
you got to do now on the flip side of it
anytime you push things down people's
throat they're gonna push back in their
own way one of the ways they're going to
push back is there was a whole group of
people that went and did what they did
with Afghanistan and they're civilians
former military guys and they went and
did it on their own so like no no no
here's how we're going to do we're gonna
go out there and do it on our own so I
think you're gonna see more of that
happening what people are coming out who
are love America who are not for this
woke stuff and they're going to keep
recruiting each other and they're going
to find each other and that's going to
be a military that you and I maybe don't
know as an organized military but
they're just as good as everybody else
and maybe even better in many instances
to go out there and fight for the
country but you will never know their
names yeah I mean the the military guys
who stood up and said hey I'm sorry but
you can discharge me if you want but I'm
not getting this experimental vaccine
those are the guys I want those are the
guys that I want on the front lines
because they're people who are still
free thinking people they're still using
their minds they're still making
decisions that are best for themselves
and their family they haven't forgotten
how to think and that whole structure of
yes sir I get it I understand I went to
actually a grade school very much like
that so I understand that the value of
discipline I get it but at some point
when the apparatus above you is making
decisions that are incredibly concerning
I don't need military members to just be
a puppet of that I still need them to be
free thinking people who can make good
decisions without being puppeteered
that's my concern I I'm with you I
remember when I was in the in the Army
and Anthrax was a thing where everybody
was taking this vaccine and they came up
well you got to take it or else this or
else that or else this and our final our
Sergeant First Sergeant came out and
said listen guys you want to take it
take it you don't want to take it I'm
not going to make you take it but it's
up to you different time different time
that was 98 today 24 years late is a
completely different story that we have
so again my concern is people are so
worried about like this Stuart scheller
guy that got term you know got uh fired
resigned but he was pretty much is going
to be kicked out of the military doesn't
get his pension after 17 years just
because he got up and he said show us
some accountability why did we leave
Afghanistan right he's one of the guys
that spoke up he was a o5 he was a
lieutenant colonel who spoke up 17 years
he gave his life to the military right
afterward he got his wife left him
divorce lost all the retirement nearly
two and a half million dollars of
pension that he loses and today he was
on a podcast two weeks ago he said I
don't know what to do next I'm a little
bit lost when he was in the room you
felt the guy's a little bit lost so
people like that who question and push
back they're very important to the
country but it just tells you any
organization where there is not
discourse and debate where there's you
know sitting there saying I don't know
if we should do this why shouldn't we do
this anytime you lose that I don't know
if you're going to be making a mess the
best because no single leader knows a
hundred percent of the time that you're
always going to make the right decision
you're going to need to ask that one
question which is what what do you think
Jedediah what do you think what are your
thoughts here's what's going on this is
what we know here's the Intel that our
intelligent officer just told us what do
you think we should do what do you think
we should do what do you think we should
do are we making the right decision I
don't think we are tell me why
we're missing that part yeah I don't
want a military of robots no I don't no
I don't you don't want that would you
encourage your child your own children
to join the military as it looks uh and
as it stands in 2022.
no not the way it is today I don't but
here's here's how I sell the military as
well I sell it as in you know in the
David family your first job is to go
make money okay have your success make
your money take care of your wife take
care of your kids take care of your
family if you're a woman take care of
your finances as well and then
afterwards you got to figure out a way
to give back to this country you can
choose to give it in many different ways
some give it through education some give
it through non-profits some is through
church some is through charity some is
through public you know politics but you
got to give back because this country is
here before us and it gave us an
incredible life and it's going to be
here after us so no matter how much we
win we have to figure out a way to give
back so if if my kids if one of the boys
wants to I have them watch military
movies all the time yeah so we watch
military movies because I want them to
see that's honor you see that right
there that's a hero right there look
what that guy did right there that's
respect for what he did so they in our
household they look in military as
Heroes but also we question a lot of BS
with them all the time should women be
in the military
I wouldn't want my daughter to join the
Army
from the stories I hear with navy and
the Marines probably not Air Force I
don't think it's a bad idea for Air
Force for somebody that wants to go in
and she's tough like you know Vinnie's
sister was in the Air Force she's about
to retire 20 years I don't think I think
Air Force is fine I just know how it was
in the Army when I was in and how women
were treated and I I don't know if I
would want my daughter to go in the army
if you want to watch the full episode
you're going to click right here and if
you want to ask me a question one on one
you want to do a one-on-one face time
with a group of your friends whatever
you want you need to download manect
right now click right here and let's get
talking
[Music]